if there is
anything that needs to be uh satirized
and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample
trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
big
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as opposed to once
[Music]
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
cost of the election
what is going on here what is
[Music]
what is going on
[Music]
all right let's get into it the house of
representatives
right now is debating whether or not to
do
a commission to investigate
what happened on january 6th meaning the
trump riots
um and we are sort of monitoring it
i don't know that any big decisions are
going to necessarily be reached today we
know that mitch mcconnell just came out
against it
uh but let's just listen to a little bit
but i have so many things to go over
with you that we're just gonna sort of
monitor this to see if they come to any
kind of conclusion or vote
but it's a lot of banter let's see who
worked hard to get to this place
and got what the minority leader asked
for
except for the distraction
except for the dissembling he didn't get
that
but he got everything else
mr speaker i hope my republican
colleagues
will think not about
their politics
not about the former president
not about themselves
i hope they will think of the country
right of this congress
of this house
yeah so they're going to continue
debating and we will monitor it and
hopefully
i mean we want an investigation trump
doesn't and we'll get to that
uh in a little bit um okay where to
start
um oh okay so there's already a super
chat i know you can't see it on screen
because the first three just don't show
up
hey david what are your thoughts on the
clip of vosh calling you a zionist do
you think his comments were fair
i haven't seen it but people have been
sending me messages saying that vosh and
i don't think
people don't mean chris vosh the
basketball player right
they mean vosh the streamer um neil
neil vosh um that vash
is attacking me over something and then
that
hassan is attacking me and saying that
i'm trash
if that's true i want hassan on here
right now
right now and we will talk about that um
but
like i just don't care you know it's
like zionist it's a pejorative
come on guys ask me about policy ask me
about policy it's just ridiculous
um but no i haven't seen any of it if
people give me send me clips i will look
at them
but i just have no idea i'm so busy with
my show and my gardening and now
starting to look at
you know what our vacation is going to
look like we've hired someone new we're
starting a second youtube channel we're
going to start doing a sort of
um uh a fight back against prageru where
we're gonna start doing our own
explainers without the ludicrous
right-wing slant like we have so many
projects it's just projects projects up
the wazoo
um so i have no idea what anybody said
and if vash wants to come on here and
say whatever he wants or
hassan's welcome right now if he wants
to explain to me how i'm trash like i i
i'm fine i guess although i don't know
who like benefits from the drama
uh hassan's a much bigger streamer than
me so it seems like it's almost good for
me which is
why i'm saying get them on here right
now and we'll talk about it
um but i don't i don't care you i just
don't know um
okay where to start though
um oh yeah so the second channel this is
a really big as you know we're hiring
someone new and so we're going to
dramatically expand sort of our
day-to-day
capacities and we're going to start a
second channel the second channel is
going to include
clips from the live streams so
we we don't clip the live stream because
we just don't have room on our regular
channel
we're going to take the um interesting
clips from the live streams
and put them on channel number two i
need ideas for the name we're thinking
pakman live
i don't know and we're gonna integrate
some more kind of like
non-political stuff and we may also take
some of the not so good live calls that
right now go on the main channel
we may push them to the clips channel
for content purposes
and just to kind of clean up the main
channel a little bit
so there's a lot happening this is a lot
that's going on we're going to be
bringing it very very hard
on um tick tock we're going to expand on
tick-tock we're gonna launch youtube
shorts
not sharts i already see people it's
youtube shorts
um there's just a lot coming into the
david pakman show
universe and um
hassan says he doesn't want to talk to
me okay i mean again whatever
i i have an agenda here um you know my
legal pad is filled with
notes and things so that's totally fine
if people want to
attack me for the memes or for the
content or because they're making money
someone what was that thing yesterday uh
central corporation someone said was
talking about me and it was like a he
central committee yeah and i was like i
hope they made some money i hope they
got some clicks and made some ad sense
right i don't
i don't i just can't keep up with it all
it's so crazy
um
okay oh hold on a second
we do have to man ban hammers are coming
fast and furious i might have said
something that triggered someone
the other thing yesterday people emailed
me after the stream
and said would i take personal finance
questions here because
i mean sure i'll take them um people may
not know but i actually have a master's
degree in financial planning but that
was like 12 years ago
so i'm glad to take personal finance
questions
they would i would not be giving
financial advice would be the caveat but
if people want to send
personal finance questions i'll try it
and see if i can just generally if i
still have any chops
in that space um
okay what else um
personal finance second channel we
talked about oh
i got a beautiful message this is the
funniest message
you know how so many people have trouble
um like connecting amazon prime to
twitch prime and then signing up like i
always hear from it i got the most
delightful message
yesterday where um a guy named greg
said linking prime with twitch
to give david the free sub token he
asked about
nearly made my head explode finally
after an hour i learned
it does work on ios and yes i'm over 50
thanks
if this gentleman spent an hour doing it
then that's really nice i don't know
what but my message is
you don't have to send it to me just
make sure you're
using your twitch prime sub if you're
not on amazon prime
because otherwise it's just five bucks
you're leaving in bezos's pocket and
that seems crazy
um oh no what is happening in the chat
we are going to have to start
dropping so many band hammers here
oh god there's it's like i can't even
keep
up with some of what these people are
doing but it doesn't seem good
mods please keep an eye out on what's
going on because it's it's getting very
ugly
i want to say thanks to jimmy 10 pins
for the 16 months
twisted hawk for the five months jp
black for the four months
um very much appreciate that kicking us
off putting us at three
for the day also big thank you to
christine schneider for signing up at
joinedpakman.com
and thanks to tristan edge a very edgy
name
new members four and five at
joinpackman.com yeah trolls are coming
out of nowhere guys i don't know if
they're coming from
chris vosh or hassan or where they're
coming from but people are
on fire um okay let me look at a few
super chats and then we'll sort of get
into
the meat of today's stream azar says if
the trump riot wasn't an insurrection
because of semantics
then asylum seekers aren't illegal
aliens abs that's that's a good analogy
actually
that's a good analogy joseph thompson
says i got a question does congress have
any other way of barring former
president trump from
ever running no i don't not that i'm
aware of now
david is it time to go out and get
popcorn and watch and affordi and watch
trump do his perp walk okay let me
address that
so i have you know how trump was going
to launch this new communications
platform
and it was going to revolutionize social
media and then it was just a blog it was
like blogspot got installed on donaldj
trump.com i haven't been looking at it
for weeks because it's like who cares
what trump is writing about
but um i once it was announced that now
there are two
criminal investigations into the trump
organization i went over to trump's blog
look at this wall of text that trump
wrote look at this
and i'm actually gonna review this
tomorrow on the show
um isn't that insane like let's just
look at a little bit of it okay
yeah i don't know if the explanation is
adderall uppers downers confusion
senility i don't know what okay let's
get let's get right into it
i have just learned through leaks in the
mainstream media that after being under
investigation from the time i came down
the escalator five and a half years ago
including the fake russia-russia-russia
hoax the two-year 48 million dollars no
collusion molar witch-hunt impeachment
hoax number one impeachment hoax number
two and others
that the democrat new york attorney
general has informed my organization
that their investigation is no longer
just a civil matter but also potentially
a criminal investigation working with
the manhattan district attorney's office
there is nothing more corrupt than an
investigation that is in desperate
search of a crime but make no mistake
that is exactly what is happening here
the attorney general oh god ban hammers
please we gotta start banning these
people guys
uh if i have to start dropping the bands
i will do it myself
ban oh my god it is insane what is going
on
okay that's the first sentence the
attorney general of new york literally
campaigned on prosecuting donald trump
before
even before she knew anything about me
she said that if elected she would use
her office to look into every aspect of
my real estate dealings
she swore that she would definitely sue
me she boasted on video that she would
be and i quote a real pain in the ass
she declared just wait until i'm the
attorney general's office and i've got
my eyes on trump tower
she also promised that if elected she
would join with law enforcement and
other attorney generals across this
nation in removing this president from
office and it's important that everyone
understand that the days of donald trump
are coming to an end
the attorney general made each of these
statements but not after having had
an opportunity to actually look at the
facts but before she was even elected
before she had seen even a shred of
evidence
this is something that happens in failed
third world countries not the united
states
if you can run for a prosecutor's office
pledging to take out your enemies and be
elected to that job bipartisan voters
who wish to enact political retribution
then we are no longer a free
constitutional democracy
likewise the district attorney's office
has been going after me for years based
on a long discredited low life who was
not listened to or given credibility by
other prosecutorial offices
and sentenced to three years in prison
for lying and other events unrelated to
me
all right anyway um
uh so anyway trump very very triggered
very very triggered and we're
we will talk about that tomorrow but
trump is not pleased that there is now a
second
criminal investigation going on okay
other super chats coming in oh so the
answer is it is time to go get popcorn
and a 40.
yes but i don't believe trump will be
perp-walked but he will be triggered
that's for sure
mark schwartz says a debate what is
there to debate a commission
is a given no de otra
i thought it was the way i know that
phrase
i liked your takes the other day but
what you said about the pcrf was
incorrect and you might want to look
into it all right if people want to send
me information i'm glad to do that
brody mulligan says what can people do
now to help win the
midterms register and start deciding
which races you want to get involved in
it may be too early but soon it will be
there will be
specific options focus in on one or two
races you want to get involved in
john says if republicans win the 2022
midterms do you think republicans will
impeach biden
to get revenge on dems for impeaching
trump keep in mind this is the current
republican party we're talking about
they actually may yeah
i would be worried about that
crazy you brought up your masters
why is that crazy i was explaining why
people want me to answer personal
finance questions
it seems mentioning i have a master's
degree
in in financial planning seems very
relevant
um i do have a question it's not
personal but i've had the question for a
while can i get on the next discord
matty you should with peace and love you
should have just asked the question
right now i would be answering it right
now instead of wondering what it is
what is the controversy with hassan
joining the stream
i have no idea someone told me that
hassan told said that i'm trash
and i said bring him on right now i will
talk to him right now
um it might all be a joke i have no idea
people talking about crypto yep we've
got the bitcoin price right here there
was a big
calamitous drop this morning and then it
recovered
i sold nothing as many of you know so
listen
i'll be i'll just be very real basically
i got to the point
of being up 10x on my bitcoin and i've
been selling
tranches of bitcoin since january 1st
uh 5 10 at a time every time it reached
a new high
i sold like 5 percent and then when it
got beyond that i sold another five ten
percent
i'm playing at this point with the
house's money i sold nothing
i bought nothing i'm not buying the dip
i'm not selling the dip i'm not i'm just
that's it i'm just waiting i didn't do
anything
and you know uh jp morgan and others
have a hundred thousand dollar
price target by the end of the year
maybe they're right maybe they're wrong
um that's it okay i don't know anything
about it
hassan is banning people thrashing you
in his chat
don't buy into the drama that's nice wow
uh if hassan let's let's check that out
let's see hassan banson people
hassan twitch let's see
i would love to see some band hammers
being dropped for trashing me
that's the way it should work it should
be against the law
all right we'll come back to that um
other super chats is kevin mccarthy with
a queue
using the gate strategy where he lies
and obfuscates until the point where
he's actually in cuffs yeah i think he
is
and i would love to see that listen i
don't think there's gonna be a trump
perp walk
i hope i really hope that there is a uh
matt gates perp walk all right let's see
here what's going on
well how long are these ads let's take a
listen
i think elected officials are catching
up with where the people across the
country are because
all right he's just watching videos
state capitals
i have too big of an agenda to just
watch that but thanks to hassan if he's
banning people for trashing me
thanks to daniel garrison daniel
garrison just got a perfect membership
at joinedpakman.com
and his new member number six today i
also want to say thank you to
whoa big sub dumps here on twitch r
wester hanging from gallows seven months
akira loves ruji four months
two hot nelly first month denon
cleo second month red team go
three months kino hermes seven months
trigono new a prime sub that's number
eight
uh okay i think that's it what's 8 plus
6
14. thank you really appreciate that
really really appreciate that and uh
yeah there's been some hate
cancellations
honestly you know here's the real thing
this is so i'm going to be very real
with people now usually everything on
this show is a farce
i'm going to be very real um
i don't really care about like the
persistent
2000 anti-semitic comments a day or any
of that stuff
because those really that's not my core
audience what really has bothered me is
there's been about like a dozen people
who didn't even watch my segment on
monday
on the israeli-palestinian conflict who
wrote in saying that
based on things they heard on other
channels they're canceling their website
memberships that actually does bother me
because
i have no problem if someone cancels
because they actually disagree with me
on what i've said i think if you support
independent media as an institution and
we agree on 95 percent of things
you know you can make a case why cancel
over one issue or two issue or three
that's a different question but when
people literally cancel it's not a
figurative cancellation
it's there's a red cancel button and
they've pressed it
because of something they heard i said
which i didn't really say
that gets to me because we're never
getting anywhere if that's
the strategy right listen to what i said
on monday
in the 20 minutes um
meme burst ships yeah it becomes you it
goes from being a membership
to merely a meme mership memebership
membership that's tough to say uh that
actually does bother me
because um you know it's regressive
it's regressive i would say that
absolutely absolutely
should we do space travel someone is
asking me yes
we should all right cancel that cancel
that
but in all seriousness better 21
is a coupon code you can use at
joinpakman.com and
we will i will thank i will say things
that are so nice they're not even true
about people that sign up today all
right
let me get through the super chats and
then we'll move on kathy says pacman
playback for the second channel
i don't know what that means
uh should i invest in dogecoin i would
never tell anyone whether to do
oh hold on this is tim ryan losing his
mind hold on partisanship
what else has to happen in this country
cops
friend of the show right here in the
face to every rank and file cop
in the united states if we're gonna take
on china
if we're gonna rebuild the country if
we're gonna reverse climate change
we need two political parties in this
country that are both living in reality
and you ain't one of them
members are reminded to direct their
comments to the chair
the gentleman from mississippi reserves
really really strong uh
circumstance there from tim ryan uh so
listen dogecoin
i've been in dogecoin for months it's
totally speculative
it's gambling it's not investing just
for the memes i got in dogecoin
and i'm just holding okay i sold like 15
at the peak and i'm just holding i think
it's probably down
who the hell knows i don't i don't
really know
how could the republicans impeach biden
when he's done nothing wrong oh they
don't care just watch them
it's crazily coincidental it's too long
for here
do you believe joe manchin truly
believes bipartisanship is possible uh
no
i don't how are they letting marjorie
taylor green without a mask she's not
vaccinated
they're all taking their masks off when
they speak did she not even wear a mask
at all
i didn't see it that's literally not
true i'm watching
hassan live one of the super chatters
was trolling him with an inappropriate
question he actually likes you oh okay
cool
you should have seen hassan take down uh
indian food when we when we had dinner
in la he was going
nuts he put in an order i got calls from
doctors and they said we've never seen
an order like hassan put in
uh it was really something else and he
had like multi i think this is okay to
say
he had multiple hipster sodas during our
dinner you know how it's like
there's coca-cola okay fine but you know
how there's these hipster sodas that are
like the same thing but
it's just a different name you know like
uh
joe's joe's root beer or whatever he was
just
or was it stephen kenneth who was
ordering the sodas now i don't remember
might have been both of them i don't
even know
anyway there was a lot of strange soda
how about these celtics and jason tatum
it's something else it's absolutely
something else
is a 2024 trump run impacted by his
pension claim
no it's not do you ever work with tyt
jesse dolimore or btc
no wait i just kind of do my own thing
um i really only know the people at tyt
i don't know jesse dollamore or btc
but i'm always up for doing stuff if
people want to do it
all right let's get to a um
unban request i do want to say thank you
to lee smith for signing up at
joinpackman.com new member number 15
today also thank you to red benny for
the twitch prime sub
um yeah
number 16 today really appreciate that
and by the way you know what i'll do
again today
patreon pledges count double a
membership on twitch counts as one
a website membership counts as one today
only and yesterday but today only
uh patreon counts as two patreon.com
david pakman show okay here is
a a person who wants to be unbanned
i don't even have my gavel today this
person
subscribed today or followed
on twitch today they sent one two
three four five six seven links which
were
spam filtered then they sent
f david pakman wall of text they were
banned
and then their unban request is a link
to a youtube clip that i'm not going to
click on
so that is denied and made perma
that's a perma-ban it's just i just have
no patience for that stuff
it's like it's not even really a reason
to be unbanned here is a
um interesting voicemail this is
something
something happened to someone with the
vaccine and their membership let me
listen to this i don't even know what
this is about
hi david p this is fernando
winchester yeah that's too interesting i
was
curious about something um i
had a membership twice and both times
i went on vacation the week after that
i'm just saying
i don't know i got my guys seen earlier
it hurt like a [ __ ] it was the jnj
people are telling us
here in i live in indiana
they do not like that vaccine in this
town what do i tell them what do you
tell them how can you tell them anything
they don't understand yeah i gotta go to
the top behind me
okay so a very um high stress voicemail
there
i don't know what to tell the anti-vaxx
people in your town i mean you know i
would say just don't even worry about
them but the thing is
we want people to get vaccinated so that
we can safely get out of the pandemic so
i might tell them do you accept science
uh i i would say have you accepted jesus
into your life
being indiana and if they say yes i
would say
i have something with far more evidence
that you should accept and it's called
the vaccine maybe i would try that i
don't know
i really don't know um
[Music]
okay all right so we did the hassan
stuff we did bitcoin price
oh here's something i want to ask people
about i i've not
um mentioned this on the stream ever
before
as as we watched some of the closing
arguments here before presumably before
a vote on whether there will be
a um a commission to investigate january
6th
i've been having um sort of like a weird
back
pain thing for for a couple months off
and on
and um a couple people i know
said you know you should really go see a
chiropractor and i basically consider
chiropractic
to be a scam and um just to give you
sort of like a sense of it here's a
chiropractic
thing from rational wiki chiropractic is
the theory and practice of correction of
quote vertebral subluxation
processes to treat and cure a supposedly
vast array of diseases with no
scientifically verified connection to
vertebral anatomy
this means cracking the spine uh because
the spine being the center of all nerves
in the body is connected to everything
you know there's like a whole theory
theory of it and it strikes me as a
complete and total scam just like
absolute and complete and total scam
i've seen some chiropractors who talk
about you know flushing the toxins
afterwards by drinking water
and it's like wait so the chiropractic
stuff
releases toxins from the spine
into the kidneys which is why you're
drinking water like it just doesn't even
really make sense it's just it's all
very weird and i spoke to some doctors
actual doctors and they said uh not only
they said listen here's the opinion from
doctors that i've gotten
um some of the stuff can be dangerous
so some of it maybe there's a placebo
effect some of it is not that different
than massage
but some of the next stuff you can
really do some some damage and i spoke
even to an emergency room doctor who
said i've had people come in
with emergencies related to chiropractic
but
then someone else sent me stuff like
this and i had no i guess this is a
whole
youtube space where like people film
chiropractic videos this seems
completely insane to me
so needless to say i was like thinking
maybe i would go
just for kicks and it would be you know
for the content
but a lot of this stuff does not really
seem seem safe look at this
this one's great
there we go and also i love how this guy
acts like everything he's doing is
obviously the treatment for whatever
like the problem is for this woman yeah
also this is like deliberately
sexualized it's it's all very weird
and the other thing i've noticed which
makes me very skep let me see if there's
one where this guy brings out like a gun
let me see here oh no here's some neck
stuff that's really
all weird let's clear this one first so
we're gonna come right around here
and drop that right shoulder down just a
little bit oh it's your god
so i uh
in any case um one of the things i've
noticed
looking at these videos people have sent
me is that no matter what
problem the person goes in with
they do the exact same quote adjustments
they'll
say different things like one person
went in with scoliosis
one person went in with a shoulder thing
the other person went in with lack of
flexibility
the treatment is identical for every
single condition
except they say different things it all
seems
really weird to me so anyway long story
short
um at one point for like a minute i was
like
maybe i'd go and get some chiropractic
treatment
out of a sheer curiosity but then when i
spoke to actual
medical doctors they said you know
the especially the neck stuff could be
really bad
um and in addition when i see the exact
same
treatment for every condition it just
seems really weird
so oh there's chiropractic
fails
see that that sounds interesting the
creepiest chiropractor on youtube
let's see that big doctors do you want
to see a 60 year old man
make a 40 year old woman cry do you want
to see people's heads get ripped
yeah this thing right here the doctor i
spoke to
said absolutely never ever ever ever
like just never ever ever ever all right
we're off of the chiropractic stuff
oh let's listen let's go to something
else that's morally depraved and
disgusting
which is kevin mccarthy
the centers for disease control and
prevention issued a guidance on march 13
2021 stating that americans who are
fully vaccinated against covet 19
no longer need to wear a mask indoors or
outdoors in almost all scenarios
whereas the three widely available
vaccines against coveted 19 are highly
effective
are they trying to vote on no more masks
in the house is that what they're doing
right now
16th that it is very unlikely that a
vaccinated person
even if there's a breakthrough infection
would transmit it to someone else
whereas those who are fully vaccinated
are shown not to carry the viral load
necessary to spread the virus
and therefore do not pose a significant
look at how the speaker's texting
do you see the do you see that right
there
at best texting at worst doing something
much worse definitives
whose personal physician for various
reasons may recommend that they do not
receive the vaccine
whereas those who want to continue
wearing a mask or taking other forms of
precaution may do so whereas members of
the house of representatives have a
responsibility to send a message to the
american people that we okay
so i guess the answer is no on my
chiropractic adjustment
i do want to say thank you to jon
snowden for the twitch sub combo
carl 10 months subbed on twitch
giggle mcgoogle's has signed up
um that's three putting us at 19.
also want to say a really big thank you
these are these are some of the best
people
richard morris just got a sub on my
website
joinpakman.com and paid full price if
you can imagine that
also want to say thank you to
aristocracy
streamer okay who paid full price as
well
thank you new members 20
and 21 very much appreciate that
um other super chats chiropractics are
for injuries and
misalignments not curing disease see
that
i don't know a misalignment my
understanding is like if you have
scoliosis
you either need to deal with it early in
life with a brace or you need surgery
i don't know how just like pushing on
someone's back and cracking
would actually realign something that's
misaligned it just doesn't strike me as
it just it doesn't seem to pass the
sniff test for me
david is a great resource he often
brings things to mind that i have never
looked into i post his content on other
sites says rebuttals thank you
talk send massages use hammer chisel and
slapping you should check one out it's
hilarious
this is spider-man elsa youtube stuff
david long time listener with a very
conservative family do you think biden
will push for more gun legislation
maybe maybe a lot of stress goes right
to my back regular massage works well
ed gainey won the pittsburgh mayor race
with predicted at five cents yesterday
what does it say about prediction marks
who do you think will win new york city
i think it'll be adams or yang i don't
know
um okay what is this motion is this a
motion to get rid of masks or a motion
to table the motion to get rid of masks
does anybody know
or is this a vote on the insurrection
commission i don't even know what
they're voting on
republicans are all saying no
it seems it's a vote as to whether to
continue talking about masks right
this is a motion to move to table for
the attending physician to update
guidelines
okay
very good
yeah i guess it seems that what
democrats want to do is just table this
for the time being
and then discuss ending the mask
requirement at some future point that's
what it seems like is going on to me
um
david would you ever interview abby
martin on the show she's doing a lot of
work in israel palestine i find
insightful maybe
kstp i live in california 23 kevin
represents bakersfield and democrats ran
a candidate from quartz hill
he got 70 of the vote in 20 just for
being local realistically how can we get
him out of office it's tough to get
people like kevin mccarthy out of office
very very tough
chiropractic manipulation doesn't change
someone's anatomy unless they fracture
someone's bones that's what i believed
yeah
wait until you've seen the world of baby
chiropractors if your interest is peaked
i think you mean p-i-q-u-e-d youtube
spine surgeon reacts to infant
chiropractic manipulations i don't think
i have the uh
i don't think i have the stomach for
that right now
in regards to cancer culture do you
think kathy griffin should have been
fired for the fake trump head stunt
no i think she should not killing the
president in effigy is not illegal i'd
say the same thing if celebrity did it
with biden
yeah i agree with you recently lost
everything in a house fire i'm so sorry
to hear that andrew
this is the first time i've gotten to
relax and watch a live stream since the
incident great to be back
great to have you back i'm really sorry
to hear that
on the chiropractor thing a guy in
australia does pretty good in-depth
study of the patient and focuses on
minor
adjustments i just wonder about the term
adjustment altogether like is it even
really like are you really adjusting
anything
i just don't know that that's that's
even the right term for it
i want to say thank you to jensen rowe
jensen just grabbed a subscription on my
website and his new member number 22.
also want to say thank you to ky dizzle
for eight
months subscribed very much appreciate
that
okay let's get to some other things as
we wait for this vote
tucker i haven't watched this i guess
tucker was very
mad today about what he's calling an
airline
humiliation tactic let's take a listen
not to get personal but how much do you
weigh you may find out the next time you
fly
trace gallagher is here with this heavy
news
tucker we tend to forget that weight
gain can increase the risk of diabetes
heart disease and
plane crashes weight and balance is very
important to aviation safety and in 2019
the faa issued an advisory
to stress the importance of airlines
getting good estimates on how much
weight their planes are actually
carrying and because the faa has noticed
that americans have put on more than a
few pounds
there's now a push to consider weighing
plus size
passengers we're told it won't be
anything as abrupt as tsa agents saying
take off your shoes pull out your
laptops and hop on the scale
but apparently scales and weight numbers
will be at airports at some point in
time
though the numbers will be hidden away
and you can always decline
to be weighed and they just choose a
different traveler tucker
amazing now i thought that
tucker is the type of guy who thinks fat
shaming is a good way to get people to
lose weight
it's getting more fun to fly tres
gallagher thank you you bet
that's it for us tonight reminder
kirstie alley and tucker carlson today
okay yeah i mean listen i've been
talking about the passenger of size
thing for a long time and i think it's
an issue that can be dealt with
respectfully
um you know to to some level um
the the the question is how much
does a few uh passengers of size
see here's the thing you don't you
shouldn't really need to weigh people
because the way that this is supposed to
work
is if at check-in or boarding
um employees notice a passenger of size
that should have two seats instead of
one
the fact that they're getting two seats
means you're taking away a person from
the plane
and it really should average out you
would think so i guess
statistically i don't know why you would
need to weigh individuals because
if they're small enough to fit into one
seat then
that's your measure and if they're not
then they should have two seats and then
that's one per i don't know
i don't know yeah i'm just not sure
about this but it's just weird because i
think
tucker is part of the fat shaming is a
good idea thing
but then he doesn't want this i don't
know it's all kind of weird i guess
nation and now the great sean hannity
from new york
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to
wow yeah okay all right yeah i don't
know too much about that but it does
seem like a statistical question let's
listen
um let's take a listen to this is our
friend ruben gallego right who's been on
the show
whoop on the motion to table
what the heck
okay looks like a proxy vote i guess i
don't know
interesting um can
super chat can i say destiny's full name
oh yeah stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell ii you have to fade away from
the mic when you do it
i had a rough massage experience the
therapist jumped on my back
and felt like i was roughed up but
actually loosened up tension well yeah
licensed massage therapy and
chiropractic are two different things
are these proxy votes
i inform the house that miss maxine
waters will vote yes
on the motion to table okay so these are
just proxy votes
um okay bernie sanders on the senate
floor now
calling for an immediate ceasefire in
gaza
all right let's see if we can find
bernie on the floor of the house
uh for the senate rather
senate live
um let's see here
i'm not finding the senate stream
actually
see the c-span have it
um
[Music]
yeah i'm not finding it for whatever
reason
it's on his twitter
okay all right maybe we'll go to that a
little bit later
uh mds don't usually treat holistically
that's the problem with taking mds as
ultimate they're trained to correct just
the symptoms in most cases
gotta find a better md then um
okay
all right very good so we've gotten that
out of the way now
i do wanna look at the recent joe rogan
comments a bunch of people sent me this
and said they would like to hear
my thoughts joe wrote whoa hold on a
second what was that
joe rogan recently
uh saying something about woke something
about woke i don't know let's take a
listen to this you can never be woke
enough that's the problem it keeps going
it keeps going further and further and
further down the line and if you get
to the point where you capitulate where
you
agree to all these demands it will
eventually get to
straight white men are not allowed to
talk right because it's your privilege
to express yourself when
other people of color have been silenced
throughout history it will be
you're not allowed to go outside because
so many people were imprisoned for so
many years i mean i'm not joking no
that that last thing is a little bit
extreme i'll give you i have to actually
have a lot of thoughts on this but let's
listen to it all no i know it really
will get there
it's that crazy you know we just got to
be nice to each other man
and there's a lot of people that are
taking advantage
of this weirdness in our culture and
then that becomes their thing
their thing is calling people out for
their privilege calling people out
okay so i think joe rogan goes way too
far here
and this this issue of you know wokeness
and uh
um who gets to speak and all this
different stuff
it it's being dramatically overblown
so here's my take on it um
in general critical let's let me see i
want to make
i want to make this like a seven head
take i don't want to just kind of like
throw out some stuff here i really want
to like address this
because this is a real issue and i think
there's an important conversation here
let me see if i can gather my thoughts
um a lot of these modern
critical theories um that include
critical race theory
and uh others sort of were
birthed by um
foucault uh post-modernism
um and they focus for my
take from for my for my taste and from
from my perspective
uh too much on all narrative
is valid and uh
language okay now the
is the word fucoian is that a word can
someone just
quickly uh uh gut check me on that is
that the term foucaulian
dear god no one knows it is now okay
people know what i mean
the fucoian um a postmodernist idea
was actually a really great thing
for the analysis of literature of
literature
okay the problem that i have
is that when applied to a lot of
other areas whether it's the economy
whether it's race whether it's
a privilege so all these other things
it essentially makes it impossible
for us to say hey you know what not all
ideas are valid
not every narrative deserves an equal
seat at the table
etc and this really goes both ways
because the right loves to critique the
left
along the lines of every narrative is
equally valid and and all this other
stuff
by saying look by the left's
philosophy on this um
any understanding about economic
struggles
is equally valid and we can't say that
just doesn't make any sense that's not
based on fact
we don't need to really consider that
okay i heard it it makes no sense
we're eliminating that from the
discussion and
what you get when you're uh driving
a principle is that all narratives are
equally valid
and especially narratives attached
to certain language or certain identity
are
more valid that is a problem
that is a problem and this is not me
going anti-woke or or anything
the the point is that the foucault
ian a postmodernist
ideas which did a lot of great things
for analysis of literature
i don't think are serving us
particularly well in some of these
other areas and uh there's one more
aspect to this
okay the focus on language
so like many of you know that i am i am
latino and hispanic or whatever
according to the u.s census i was born
in argentina spanish is my first
language etc
a really big fight right now that's
happening
in some circles and again most people
who just work don't care about this
they really don't and it's also a
movement that's not actually being led
by latino and hispanic people
this entire latinx thing where latino
with the o is by default
masculine and so there's all these
different
adjustments that some are making for
example instead of saying latino you say
latin
x which could be latino or latina or
there's another one where the word in
spanish for everybody is
todos now todos is masculine
if you had a group of only women you
would say todas
there's a new movement which says well
make it t-o-d-x-s
and it's like well but how do you
pronounce that so then when you say it
some people are saying to this with an e
which is not a word
and um the idea of this
is if you change the language
to be gender neutral you will change
society i just don't agree that that's
the case
and so this is another thing that comes
from the the foucaulian
school uh of the importance of language
and i know the idea of if you control
the language you control
people's minds or i don't i think i
don't remember if it was edward
edward bernays or who said that i have a
different view which is
let's actually fix the problems before
the law
when the law is relevant through
education
and then the language will either adjust
on its own
or um it will be irrelevant and we will
say you know
i don't really care that the default is
todos which
which is masculine because we've solved
the actual issue of gender inequality
in this area or or in that in that uh
area and so that's my view okay so what
joe wrote
i think joe rogan's going way too far
you won't be allowed to go outside
because people have been imprisoned i
think that's silly maybe he didn't mean
it literally
but i do have critiques
of a critical theory based on
fucoian ideas and the idea of here's the
other problem i have by the way i
apologize if i'm ranting too much
oh i should stop all of this no okay
i'll finish
what uh what i'm talking about um if you
have a group and by and again the whole
latinx thing
is being driven uh not by latino and
hispanic individuals which
i think matters also to some degree but
regardless of that
imposing that we now use the term latinx
and todas instead of todos or todas etc
in spanish it's extremely top-down
it's not really the way language
develops and one of the
the way that language typically develops
actually if you look at like new guinean
language
new guinean languages um
languages kind of mix and it goes bottom
up is the point i'm trying to make
in new guinea um actually jared diamond
has a lot of great writing on this
because he studied a lot down there
in new guinea you had like i think it's
thousands of different languages
and some of them were spoke by spoken by
really small groups of people
and over time they're developed i don't
know if the word is a patois
or a creole pigeon i think is more of a
pejorative at least in some cases
but the way that it all evolved was
english speakers came over and started
appearing and working with and and
dealing with different tribes and there
started to be like an
averaging in of some american words that
were either spelled differently
pronounced differently or modified
and it's sort of like a bottom-up thing
it's not someone came in and said
we now refer we the word is now latinx
the word is now todas 800-ish languages
okay thank you
um that's i think how that's that's a
much more natural way for language to
change it's the way that language has
changed uh historically so
that's my take all of this to say
um i think joe rogan goes too far let's
listen to it one more time
you can never be woke enough that's the
problem it keeps going it keeps going
further and further and further down the
line and if you get
to the point where you capitulate where
you
agree to all these demands it will
eventually get to
straight white men are not allowed to
talk right because it's your privilege
to express yourself when
other people of color have been silenced
throughout history it will be
you're not allowed to go outside because
so many people were imprisoned for so
many years i mean i'm not joking no so
yeah
so he says he's not joking i mean that's
crazy to me i don't think that that's
going to happen
um but i think there are some really
good critiques of what's going on
in some circles in academia right now uh
the focus on controlling language
uh rather than sort of like fixing
issues in
structural ways and um the idea of every
narrative being equally valid and
everybody needs to be heard and
particularly if you attach certain
identities to certain ideas there are
bad ideas they're ideas that don't need
to be heard if you were trying to figure
out
um i don't even know i'm having trouble
thinking of an example but if you were
trying to figure out almost
anything uh you wouldn't just say
let's bring everybody to the table let's
br and every idea has to be considered
equally no you defer to actual experts
in some senses in other cases you you
sort of like screen ideas and
etc i think people get it okay
let me get to people are going crazy
in the chat and via super chat and
reacting to this maybe we should clip
this
critique and we could put it up on on
youtube let's look at some of the
reactions from people
as a mexican being a stickler for
grammar i don't like the term latinx
i'll accept it most people like it but i
didn't choose to be hispanic or even
latino
i'm not sure i know what that means
i have a vague memory of an aeroplane
crash as a consequence of the formula
used to estimate the total weight of
passengers the plane was carrying
servicemen
who were strapping young men okay
try c-span 2 for senate senate coverage
i have it on my cable provider
ironically i wanted to ask your opinion
on how to relax even when there's so
much news going on
oh you just have to take scheduled
breaks i totally check out over the
weekend
that's why when i came into my office on
monday and i had you know
40 anti-semitic messages it was all very
surprising
uh okay i think we've basically gotten
that let's see what's happening with the
vote
i'll i'll just leave volume our purpose
is the gentlewoman from washington seek
recognition
mr speaker is the member designated by
ms sewell pursuant to hres
eight i informed the house that monsieur
will vote yes
on the motion to table okay
so we're getting down to the end here
and voting going very slowly i do want
to say thank you to
devil can't cry for gifting
two subscriptions via twitch remember
guys
if you have if you have
a um amazon prime membership
you get a free twitch membership every
month give it to someone i don't care if
it's not me
although it should be but i don't care
if it's not me
don't let the five bucks sit in jeff
bezos's pocket that would be a tragedy
get your bezos bucks and make sure to
give them to someone
and i would love it if it was me why not
why not
um okay i'm seeing people asking
whether i will show the garden i
actually showed the garden yesterday
and we are going to have someone very
special
is going to be doing a react video to my
garden
very very special but i'll show it again
if people want let me just see if i can
pull it up here
garden
okay let me see here i will show
everybody my
cukes i don't have any zooks this year
but i will show people my cukes
as we wait for the results of the vote
okay here we go
uh let's can i set this to playback
playback if i could just do it slowly
then i wouldn't have to
does obs have a playback speed thing
speed ah here it is
let's do slower and see if that allows
me
okay so this is my swiss chard
it's looking really good other than that
one leaf but otherwise
i'm really pleased with what's going on
with it that's a jalapeno
pepper plant they grow really slowly but
then at the end i end up getting peppers
which is absolutely fantastic
this is my i just call it purple lettuce
when i bought it it was called gourmet
lettuce mix it's kind of like green but
then it turns purple
really just thick i already made a salad
with it
excellent stuff here's my mint i keep it
segregated because
it is extremely invasive and it came
back on its own mint is a perennial
really really great already used a
little bit of it uh this is uh some kind
of like chocolate tomato
it's like a brown tomato my genovese
basil
that's my flat leaf parsley these are
yellow
sun sugar tomatoes i think i zoom in at
some point
just a little more basil there let's see
what that is exactly
sun sugar yellow cherry hybrid tomato
or as i say hybrid here's my biggest
tomato plant this is the one i planted a
while ago it's just red
uh heirloom cherries i think
and i've got it pretty cleaned up i got
rid of the suckers and i'm just kind of
keeping keeping it as a what single stem
um these are my cukes they were planted
late
so they're pretty pathetic right now
tiny tiny cukes
but they should get going pretty soon i
have four different
sugar snap pea plants and they're
sending tendrils out like i've never
seen before
those are i'm really excited about that
this is my greek oregano perennial from
last year it's now a full
bush it went full bush
here is a banana pepper also growing
really slowly they just grow
so slow but then you get the peppers
here's my last tomato plant like an
orange or something
orange tomato and then one more pepper i
think it's a mini red
i know it's close to the tomato but i
think it'll be okay here's my
italian oregano also a perennial back
from last year already made pesto from
it that's my
uh this is my english thyme cilantro
looking really solid this year
and these are japanese eggplants i
planted the one on the right first so
it's bigger then i was i liked it so
much i did it again
so i'm uh i've never grown eggplant
before this is where i had the
um this is where i had my zooks
last year and i got three
very solid zooks and then the plant died
so that's where i'm planting the uh
eggplant this year we'll see what
happens
and then here is my look at this
strawberry bush this is now a second
year strawberry bush it is
exploded i only got six strawberries
last year
i've already got um must be 20 or 30
different flowers and buds
some of them look really good look at
that
so that's pretty good
i'm excited about the strawberry
definitely and it sent out a uh
it sent out another plant and we've got
an entire like second strawberry plant
now
so really great stuff that's it
and then oh um this is just a bonus
i also have some romaine
this is like if you need well let me
shrink this
if you need like a salad element that's
good on sandwiches
it's these right here i made it today i
made a sandwich today
and i was just they're like full leaves
and you can just place them right on
your sandwich and it's perfect
absolutely perfect
all right so that's it that's the garden
and now uh now everybody's seen it and
we're gonna have a really strong react
video coming up to that
soon um the the youtube gardening space
is highly titillated highly highly
titillated
and uh yeah you know when people brag
oh we've got uh i've already got
tomatoes i've already got peppers okay
in the northeast i mean look at what new
york weather has been like i'm doing the
best i can with the weather that we've
had like this is just
i can't control the growing season you
know all right big thank you to
leo venus
who has just signed up at joinpakman.com
and his new member number 26
also thank you to some new twitch
subscribers
raja celtic midnight
denied technique cobra commander
thanks to all four of you for the twitch
subs
okay other super chats that came in
umberto says what i meant was it can be
tough to self-identify from a checklist
even if well-meaning
absolutely absolutely i mean listen
when i did the census i had to really
think about how to answer it i didn't
know what race i was on it
let me see if i can find the 2020 census
form
i did it so long ago i don't actually
remember now
let me see if i can find it
hold on 2020 census form
i was really confused by the uh by the
questions let's take a look at them
i was like what race am i
okay explore the form how many people
okay let's just go through it
were there any additional people where
was that race part
ah date of birth ah okay is person one
of hispanic latino or
spanish origin for the census hispanic
origins were not considered races
hispanic origin can be viewed as the
heritage nationality lineage or country
of birth of the person so
i put yes i was born in argentina
i spanish is my first language my
parents are argentinian
three of my grandparents are argentinian
so i put yes
i am hispanic latino or spanish
then ah then what is person one's race
here you mark one or more boxes and
printed origins
white black or african american american
indian or alaska native chinese filipino
asian indian vietnamese korean japanese
other asian native hawaiian samoan
chamorro other pacific islander or some
other race
see more about how it should be answered
okay
you're free to choose whatever
let's see the race categories generally
reflect social definitions in the u.s
and we're not an attempt to define race
biologically anthropologically or
genetically
i think i put for the race question
because again when i when i checked my
ethnicity
it was 100 ashkenazi jewish i think i
put on the race question
that i am some other race i think that's
what i did
yeah that i i think that that's what i
did
i was really confused about how to even
answer these questions it was very
strange
uh okay so anyway that was that when
trump tried to pull troops out in 2020
do you think trump just relented when
confronted or was stonewalled and told
no
no yeah there just wasn't time it just
wasn't possible
we covered that story earlier this week
john says i don't want to get
conspiratorial but do the gop are trying
to cause
a recession to sabotage biden and
democrats
no i don't think so i don't think so
what is wokism it's undefined yeah
it's one of those flexible terms that it
means different things to different
people
thanks to kismar for gifting
five subs via twitch let's see if
they're rapping speaker is the member
designated by mr liu pursuant
daytracer's eight
and former house commissioner will vote
yes on the motion of the table
as the member does today by mr lowenthal
pursuant to hey tres eight
still proxy votes it's just going on
forever and ever and ever it's wild
lee smith says i always put human race
aline says i'm japanese born in panama
raised in brazil
live in the u.s married to a puerto
rican my poor kids are going to be lost
yeah
they are i guess um they would be
i would say your kids are per the census
yes on hispanic and latino
and then for race multiracial
i don't even know that's a tough one
that's genuinely a tough one
um i don't know how i would how i would
answer
uh okay very good listen that's it
that's everything i had for today
um we wanted to check in on the debate
here i had some things to play for you
this isn't even on the commission this
is just a vote as to whether to table
the vote on masking so that's really it
all right
i'm gonna be back with everybody
tomorrow i appreciate everybody that
subscribed i appreciate everybody that
followed
and everything people have just been
great lately other than the hundreds and
thousands of anti-semitic comments on
youtube
it's the audience has been absolutely
fantastic lately all right
thank you everybody i'll be back soon
probably with a new stream tomorrow